hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
it's been over a year since I listed the
top 12 greatest Christmas specials and
though I still stand by the list except
maybe Christmas during Christmas Carol
should have been a tie a lot of people
said there were even more special than I
was missing so much so that I pretty
much had no choice but to do another
there's so many good specials out there
lucky just keep them to one list these
are sort of the runners of the next
fence after last year's choices so get
ready because this is the return of the
Christmas specials
Jesus so let's take a look at our next
top 11 why top 11 because I'd like to go
one step beyond let's take a look the
Star Wars Christmas special
what that's not a real special it
doesn't even exist no human could be
that idiotic ly cruel well let's move on
to the real number 11 spot elf now I
have to admit I don't really see this as
a good movie well the premise is good I
feel the characters are boring the jokes
are kind of weak and the story just gets
a little too corny for me
so what propels it to being a Christmas
classic Will Ferrell he is just
hilarious I love this energy I love his
innocence and I just love his naivete
congratulations world's best cup of
coffee
great job everybody are you fine
how can not like him he's just so
delightfully annoy does someone need a
hug
this was Will Ferrell's first starring
role after he left SNL and thankfully it
completely saves the film I guess it's
just good luck that the first film you
actually starring will be watched by
millions every Christmas well let's hope
it doesn't do any yoga at Christmas
movies yeah that wouldn't work what can
I say except sometimes one really funny
man can in fact make a really funny
Christmas special call me elf one more
time call me out here an elf
the Garfield Christmas special this is
another one that when you look at it
isn't really anything spectacular it's
kind of cheesy and the songs get really
laying the cut you can never find
anybody in fact I think it's my first
special to ever have yodeling and a
Christmas song they took the old
fashioned business
but I'm like elf there are actually two
things they keep people coming back
what is Garfield of course I mean he's
just a lovable character appear cynic
but still very funny and very likable
and the other is the family I just love
these guys
if you ever grow up on a farm or knew
anyone that grew up on a farm then you
know these people
you got the homebody mother the quiet
no-nonsense father the shy sometimes
very silly brother and probably the
coolest grandmother ever I mean this
grandma kicks ass she should be at every
Christmas get-together I see you putting
on a little Bennett ah you're getting
soft Bart come on hit me right here give
me your best shot on top of that it's
decent animation the jokes are funny
enough it has a lot of that mushy stuff
that seems lame at times but at
Christmas you can let a little bit
goodbye Garfield Christmas special I'm
Mary pick for the number 10 spot
can't wait to Chris wake me when it's
through The Polar Express but only in 3d
I say this because the film on its own
is just okay and I know it sounds like
I'm trashing somebody's Christmas
special but really the things that are
good are unbelievably good and that's
what makes them stay about and this one
is no different when it's good it's
really good but at times it can feel
really manipulative like they're trying
to make a Christmas classic instead just
telling a good story it's like they said
we need a song here because most
children's classics have a song here
pudding
up the Christmas tree with friends who
come around we need a scary moment here
because most children's classics have a
scary moment here all right yeah and we
need some speech with the word heart in
it because well you know the drill
just remember the true spirit of
Christmas lies are you import' doc my
big fat plugging pack then and a cg can
be a little creepy at times like I said
when it works it's a very nice film
about the atmosphere the premise is you
need another look how they turn the
whole idea about believing in Santa
Claus sounds like a challenge of faith
which I think a lot of people can relate
to
I want to believe but you don't want to
be bamboozled you don't want to be kind
sometimes the most real things in the
world are the things we can't see
oh really makes it stand out is the 3d
only see this movie on IMAX and in 3d
you literally feel like you've been
transported to the North Pole that's
what really propels into an experience
rather than just a movie I know a lot of
times people see 3d as a cheat but with
this you really feel like you're there
and the film is shot to make you feel
that way as well glad I'm getting a
little tired of some ekits making these
damn films yes we know animation can
look realistic but if you're just going
to motion capture them anyway why not
just go back to using real friggin
actors for whatever reason he keeps
doing it Polar Express is a ton of fun
to watch and leaves you feeling that
good old-fashioned Christmas spirit on
its own it's okay but in 3d it's really
freaking cool and definitely get you in
the mood for the Christmas season but
next time could you leave the Steven
Tyler elf out seriously what the fuck
alright the Star Wars Christmas but
goddamn it we can get out of here I told
you it doesn't exist the Black Adder
Christmas Carol know granted many of you
might not even know the show Black Adder
is what's not required to totally enjoy
the special it's a British comedy
starring Rowan Atkinson Hugh Laurie and
many others since the reincarnated
through different periods in time the
character of black enters always the
world's biggest asshole that's part of
what makes the show so funny but in the
Christmas special he's the nicest man in
England I mean that well certainly here
but this all changes when the spirit of
Christmas comes to show him flashbacks
of his ancestors which are of course
from the other episodes he stopped
ironically Black Adder lights the way
his ancestors act and decides he wants
to be a jerk from now on oh we're in
love love I should warn you is like a
Christmas cracker one massively
disappointing bang and the novelty soon
wears oh it's cynical it's cruel and
it's all done in the name of goodwill
toward men now it does help to see the
original shows before watching the
Christmas special but it's not totally
necessary but the scenes of Black Adder
acting knives are a million times
funnier when you know the character
Asian is every time he smiles and laughs
you know he's for pressing a ton of
anger wants to smack someone in the face
but there must be something we can do ah
fuck the match is in your butt
it isn't just the thing I need how much
did they cost a quitter match Cratchit I
suspect that to be a lie of sorts and
luckily my head he does I've made you a
pissed
wonderful about it is that you use it
again again and again
Thank You mr. B it's funny it's dark
it's a perfect offset to all the
Yuletide cheer we're so used to getting
this time of the Bing where's the milk
of human kindness it's gone off Bullock
it's brown
yeah I know many of you would consider
this a Christmas movie but I'm surprised
to find just how many people with this
movie out around this past year I guess
who doesn't want to see red eye theme
that's attack innocent bystanders while
singing holly jolly Christmas tunes but
the more I thought about it yeah I just
surprisingly think of Christmas might
think of this movie I remember gizmo
given as a present I remember that
gremlin in the tree grabbed a dog
wrapped up in Christmas lights I even
remember that goddamn fucking weird
speech about Santa Claus it just came
out of nowhere now I have another reason
to hate Christmas it was Christmas Eve I
was 9 years old I went to try to light
up the fire and that's when I noticed
the smell and me and mom expecting them
to pull out a dead cat or a bird and
instead they pulled out my father he was
dressed in a Santa Claus suit he slipped
and broke his neck that's how I found
out there was no Santa Claus um thanks
I'll be enough in some deranged sick way
this onesie did match to tie in a lot
with Christmas weird huh I don't even
know what else to say about it be honest
I'm a little disturbed by the next such
a joyous time of year with such
hell-raising little maniacs and the fact
that a lot of other people do too but
hey if everyone is watching at this time
of year at least I know I'm not the only
one is going crazy and at least I can
enjoy Christmas with all the other nut
balls watching you with
Allyson's the nativity well yeah sort of
a no-brainer
the story of Christmas wouldn't be here
without the story of Christmas it's
pretty straightforward though they do
and dress some areas of the story but
many of overlooked like Joseph's
reaction that Mary apparently had a
virgin birth he's not ready to actually
stone her until the angel finally
appears and said things right
oh really macula contention huh all the
son of God he had the Lord of all no
kidding uh uh well I'm gonna give the
Archangel two seconds before it's gone
getting lucky I also really enjoy the
three wise men on this movie they're
actually really likable a tad bit goofy
they're not too much that's over-the-top
but my problem I have is that the
spiritual aspect almost seems rushed at
times every time the angel appears it's
like a drive-by prophecy did you bring
back what the rest of the film is good
it's thoughtful and heartwarming and
it's very engaging to watch but some
reason the film got really panned by
critics I'm not entirely sure why maybe
because he was following on the heels of
the passion and everyone thought we were
gonna see more religious say this porn
after that I don't know but the film is
good and seriously overlooked in fact
I'm curious to see what else the
director of this movie has directed
recently
ah well trust me when I say this film is
good and you haven't seen it yet check
it out this Christmas that means Jesus
is birthday for crying out loud
you on that
Pinky and the brain Christmas special
how can you go wrong with pinky in the
brain
our favorite Mouse duo vent on world
domination have a wild time trying to
insert a hypnotizing doll into Santa's
sleigh
just act natural pinky so jokes as
always are great and the characters work
off each other wonderfully but what sets
it apart from other episodes is the
ending I won't give too much away but
it's so beautifully cheesy but still
surprisingly touching that it creates a
wonderful piece of Christmas epicness
in fact I'm actually a little shocked to
hear that some people add to the
interior I know just who the fuck you
can the brain can make anyone teary-eyed
and the top of that is just funny you
can always tell them writers are working
really hard on this show and the laughs
always comes who you working for these
two Bunny the tooth fairy
Herschel the Hanukkah goblin the
animation is great the story tell arias
and the good spirit of Christmas is
always shining through it's Christmas
goal from beginning to end
all in the family the draft-dodger mom
tickets a wonder okay what is that can
you tell me what that is
off to consider while the greatest
sitcoms of all time on the Family create
a brilliantly uncomfortable scenario for
almost every episode they also did a ton
of Christmas shows as well but probably
the most poignant was the draft dodger
it's Christmas Eve at the bunkers house
and he always conservative and bigoted
Archie is eating with his family but
he's greeted by one of Mike's friends
from Canada he's breaking the law by
being there because he moved there to
avoid the draft on top of that one of
Archie's friends is invited to who
recently lost a son in Vietnam my god
The awkward machine is about to blow
again I don't really want to give
anything away so I won't say much more
but let's just say so cool boom wrote to
the president about it mr. bunker he
just couldn't come up with as many
reasons for killing people as I could
for not killing them I will also say
that you can see why the show is often
concern where the best shows ever it's
writing is so direct and so
uncompromising that you have no choice
but to confront the issues they're
talking about as always though that
makes in just the right amount of comedy
as well where you think all people in
this country can say whether or not they
want to go to all their couldn't get a
decent war off the ground that way it's
funny powerful and leaves quite an
impact but hey that's the shona nutshell
and on Christmas you can always expect
something strong and meaningful every
time
Joe us Noel this film is starting to
grow in popularity but still not a
household name
it truly is fantastic though and
deserves more recognition it's based on
incredible true stories set in the First
World War
Scottish German and French soldiers are
head-to-head in the trenches ready to
kill one another but on the night of
Christmas they all amazingly agreed to a
ceasefire because of the holiday and we
were talking about a ceasefire for
Christmas Eve they come out of their
bunkers they talk to each other exchange
pictures and even hold a mass it's
friggin unbelievable when you watch it
you really can't believe people can be
this good they form strong and powerful
friendships that they don't want to
destroy if they go back to war because
of this things get very complicated the
day after and the day after that and
even the day after that trying to kill a
man you just called your friend a few
days ago is near impossible and this
film shows the sacrifice that these men
went through so that they didn't have to
do it I can't I don't want to give too
much away but the focus is on the night
the troops stopped firing they decided
to show their fellow man the peace and
love that Christmas is all about is an
unbelievable story has captured very
well in this bill trust me when I say if
you haven't seen it yet you're in for
something special
the snowman yeah I heard a lot of you
complaining on the last list I forgot to
put this in well here is an alt animated
glory and it truly is wonderful it's
hard to describe exactly what makes it
so good I think it's just the fact that
it's a relatively simple story that
somehow really seems to teleport you to
another world there's no sound and no
dialogue but that just makes it stand
out even more the look is very unique
and really offers a warm imagine didn't
look at winter the story you've heard
before it's pretty much the tale Frosty
the Snowman the boy makes a snowman he
comes to life he flies well that's
fucking cool and he takes him to a
rockin party where there's like a
bajillion other snowmen do it I want to
go to a snowman party not heads the only
downside I have to admit is the ending
it's not really bad or anything but it's
just so damn depressing and there's not
one happy thing about it those
children's classics have something
uplifting at the end but this film is
just like nope life sucks
Merry Christmas it pisses me off every
time how dad it showed me the truth but
then again maybe that's the strength of
the piece you liked it so much that you
never want to see it end
the snowman is simply a classic no
matter how you look at it
Christmas special is dying 8,000 pounds
it takes place at Christmas therefore
it's a freakin Christmas movie one of
the best action movies of all time how
can you go wrong it just kicks ass now
for all of you say oh it is nothing to
do with the Christmas spirit
fuck you with die hard oh this doesn't
talk about Santa Jesus or the joy of the
holidays fuck you it's die hard
if this doesn't even have a moral what
can you possibly learn from Christmas by
watching this fuck you fuck you fuck you
die r this is the action movie and every
Christmas I find more and more people
watch it around the holiday upk
motherfucker
it's Action Pack it's a great story I
mean it's very hard what more can you
say about it the title itself is
practically an explanation about why
it's so great the movie even ends with
the song let it snow
how many action movies end with let it
snow aside from die are - but die ours
is better this movie kicked ends but it
keeps even more ass at Christmas the
story straight the action is great the
acting is great it's just great
die hard the merriest explosions of
Yuletide sheer this is their idea of
Christmas I got a beer for New Year
and that's my top of it what are you
laughing at what's so funny
what is the Star Wars Christmas special
thing is that it it's not that funny
okay it doesn't exist anyway you hear me
it doesn't enter hello a package for me
oh okay thanks weird-looking mailman
haha
apparently I got a package in the mail
huh let's see what it is
No
that's not true that's along circle
features we know it to be true the price
for now
we would be honored if you would join us